Traduttore: Silvia Fornasiero
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Sembra strano, ma anche se
sono ritornato a casa in Italia
già da alcuni mesi, devo ancora
rendermi conto veramente
della portata del viaggio che ho vissuto.
Più che altro, nello specifico,
devo ancora metabolizzare
le cifre di questa mia avventura:
4300 chilometri a piedi,
6 nazioni attraversate,
84 giorni avventurosi,
9 paia di scarpe, moltissime notti
passate in tenda nei boschi,
e pochissime invece
in un letto offerto.
Più di 50 chilometri di media
giornaliera correndo
e moltissimi animali selvatici incontrati.
Ecco, questo resoconto può sembrare
frutto o di un professionista,
di un corridore,
o di un avventuriero professionista,
cosa che, vi premetto,
io non sono assolutamente,
oppure di un pazzo, magari categoria
nella quale mi vedo già meglio!
Però, scherzi a parte, io devo dirvi
che sono invece un ragazzo normale,
ma oltretutto, fino a tre anni fa,
posso dirvi di esser stato normalissimo.
E infatti non sapevo
nemmeno cosa volesse dire
correre per più di un'ora di fila.
Giocavo a calcio, andavo all'università,
avevo il mio lavoretto,
avevo la mia fidanzata,
la mia cerchia di amici.
Quindi un quadro abbastanza normale,
ma allo stesso tempo idilliaco,
che, ahimè, è cambiato comunque,
in un certo verso è andato in frantumi,
precisamente nel settembre 2012.
La mia vita è cambiata
in maniera radicale,
non perché ho vinto un qualche
jackpot o cose simili,
ma, ahimè, perché ho avuto
un grave incidente stradale.
Infatti, mentre ero in moto,
una macchina mi ha investito,
portandomi due gravi lesioni
ad entrambe le gambe,
un trauma cranico e contusioni
e abrasioni lungo tutto il corpo
che mi hanno, purtroppo, costretto
fermo a letto disteso per circa sei mesi.
Ecco, non vi nascondo che
in un primo momento
ho dovuto affrontare
una grave crisi di depressione.
Infatti, non avevo perso
con questo incidente
solamente l'intera stagione calcistica,
ma avevo perso anche il lavoro.
Dopo però questo primo momento,
veramente, ho deciso che questa pausa,
anche se forzata, doveva essere sfruttata
per un attimino guardarmi indietro
nel mio passato precedente.
Quello, però, che stavo vedendo
nel mio passato non era una cosa felice,
non era un quadro che mi piaceva,
non ero assolutamente contento
di quello che avevo costruito.
E quindi, un bel giorno,
ho deciso che quella,
seppur un'occasione infelice,
sarebbe stata invece l'occasione
per ripartire più forte di prima.
Ricordo ancora il giorno preciso
di questa illuminazione,
quando, passatemi il termine,
"correndo" con le stampelle
sono sceso giù dalle scale,
mi sono piazzato davanti alla tavola
dei miei genitori mentre stavano cenando,
e ricordo ancora queste parole:
"Papà, mamma, io appena
mi rimetto a posto fisicamente,
partirò per un'avventura grandiosa
della quale sentirete parlare
su tutti i giornali!"
Subito mio papà e mia mamma
si guardarono con gli occhi sgranati
e dettero la colpa, probabilmente,
al trauma cranico dell'incidente.
Però io in sordina, sotto sotto,
ho continuato a coltivare
questa idea senza mai mollare.
E infatti appena finita la fisioterapia,
in soli tre mesi, mi sono ritrovato
dal nulla, da zero, anzi da sotto zero,
alla linea di partenza
di questa gara: Il Magraid.
Una 100 chilometri nella steppa friulana,
che non solo sono riuscito
a portare a termine,
ma ho portato a casa anche un grandissimo
risultato in classifica, inaspettato,
che mi ha aperto le porte,
mi ha permesso di continuare
per tutte le tappe del campionato
italiano di questa categoria.
È stato veramente tosto
e difficile all'inizio,
ma anche se le montagne
che ho scalato con queste gare
sono state bellissime e magnifiche,
non mi appagavano.
E ricordo invece anche un altro
aneddoto di un giorno preciso,
quando ho alzato la cornetta
e ho chiamato il mio allenatore
e gli ho detto: "Ascolta, senti, a me
queste gare non mi soddisfano più.
Io voglio fare il giro d'Italia di corsa."
Lui si è dimostrato subito
entusiasta di questo progetto,
però mi ha dato una notizia al telefono
che mi ha subito tarpato le ali.
Infatti, purtroppo, sfortuna ha voluto
che un altro ragazzo
era proprio appena partito
per fare il medesimo
giro d'Italia, sempre di corsa,
anche se con modalità differenti.
Ma anche lì non mi sono fatto scoraggiare.
Ricordo benissimo che
sono salito subito in camera,
appena ho messo giù il telefono,
e ho srotolato la cartina
dell'Europa in cima al letto
e ho preso un compasso.
Ho puntato il compasso
sul mio paesino, Galliera Veneta,
e ho iniziato a tracciare
una circonferenza.
Una circonferenza però particolare,
che aveva come raggio
il chilometraggio d'Italia srotolato,
quindi circa 3500 km.
Subito però, nulla
lungo questa circonferenza,
nessun paese, nessuna città,
attirò la mia attenzione.
Ma appena spostai la mia attenzione,
la mia vista, leggermente più a nord,
intravidi un punto, che seppur non fosse
una città o un paese molto noto,
era comunque evidenziato e degno
di nota per la cartina geografica.
E questo punto era Capo Nord.
Ecco: non c'era bisogno
di dire nient'altro per me.
La mia avventura si stava già delineando
all'interno della mia testa.
E posso dire di avere messo
l'asticella molto, molto in alto
per essere stata la mia prima avventura,
il mio primo progetto avventuroso.
Infatti, non solo questo progetto aveva
predefinito 1000 km praticamente in più
del progetto iniziale del giro d'Italia,
ma avevo preso anche
una decisione molto importante,
che per me era fondamentale:
sarei stato completamente
da solo in questo viaggio.
Questo comportava due cose essenzialmente:
la prima di essere in completa autonomia,
quindi ero costretto a costruire
un carretto e trainarlo,
perché all'interno doveva sostenere
tutti i miei beni di prima necessità,
quali la tenda, il fornello,
il sacco a pelo eccetera,
e seconda cosa, invece,
che nei momenti di difficoltà
sarei stato completamente solo.
Infatti, questa avventura si è
differenziata da molte altre
perché, infatti, non avevo un seguito,
non avevo un cameraman,
non avevo un medico,
non avevo un fisioterapista,
un cuoco che mi seguisse.
Ecco, è stata veramente
una decisione bellissima,
e in poche settimane,
perché comunque io dovevo
alternare l'allenamento al lavoro,
sono riuscito a raggiungere
una preparazione molto buona
e finalmente il 19 aprile 2015
sono partito da Galliera Veneta.
Sono partito da Galliera Veneta,
e la previsione però era
di arrivare circa a Ferragosto.
Ma devo dire che l'entusiasmo
e la voglia di fare
e, fortunatamente, le mie gambe
erano talmente buone,
che sono arrivato un mese
prima del previsto.
Per la precisione sono arrivato
l'11 luglio, infatti a casa...
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Infatti, a casa stavano organizzando
un festone per Ferragosto
ma li ho presi in contropiede
e non abbiamo festeggiato!
(Risate)
Ecco, questo mio percorso
lo possono tranquillamente raccontare,
non io, non libri scritti o eccetera,
ma lo possono raccontare tranquillamente
le nove paia di scarpe che ho consumato.
Qualche bellissimo incontro
l'ho fatto sicuramente durante il viaggio
e ricordo questo in particolare:
ovvero, nello specifico, circa
era il nono giorno del mio viaggio
ed ero ancora in bassa Baviera,
quando a bordo strada incontrai
un signore sulla settantina
che continuava a sbracciarsi
per attirare la mia attenzione,
per invitarmi all'interno
di una stazione di servizio.
Solo che, una volta dentro,
lui non parlava inglese,
e io non parlavo il tedesco, quindi
la conversazione non stava partendo.
Fino a quando, però, lui dalla giacca
non ha estratto un articolo ingiallito.
Questo articolo ingiallito diceva
che lui negli anni sessanta
aveva costruito un carretto
quasi uguale al mio
ed era andato fino in Danimarca a piedi.
È stato bellissimo come uno sconosciuto,
quando aveva capito che io
avevo compreso la sua storia,
che anche lui aveva avuto l'opportunità
di vivere il suo sogno nella vita,
mi ha abbracciato
ed ha iniziato a piangere.
E lui, oltretutto...
(Applausi)
Grazie ancora.
E oltretutto, come uno sconosciuto
credeva veramente, anche senza conoscermi,
che io avrei portato a termine
quest'avventura difficilissima.
Invece, potete benissimo immaginare
cosa pensavano i miei concittadini
del mio piccolo paesino
quando mi vedono e mi vedevano
sfrecciare avanti e indietro,
trainando questo carretto pieno di pesi
e, oltretutto, quando mi fermavano
per chiedermi che diavoleria
avessi in mente,
io rispondevo che mi stavo allenando,
non per vincere una gara,
ma per mollare il lavoro,
per mollare tutto
e per attraversare l'Europa di corsa.
Ecco, ero diventato un po'
il pazzo del villaggio.
Però, anche qui, non ho mai
mollato la presa sul mio sogno.
Però devo essere sincero quando dico
che sono stato fortunatissimo, invece,
quando ho proposto questo mio progetto
ai miei genitori, alla mia fidanzata
e al mio allenatore.
Ecco: loro non si sono mai permessi
di dirmi che io ero pazzo,
che dovevo mettere la testa a posto,
che dovevo continuare
a fare una vita normale,
e a trovarmi un lavoro sicuro
e a rimanere qui tranquillo.
Questa è stata veramente
una spinta emotiva
che mi ha permesso di tagliare
il traguardo alla fine.
Tornando sempre al viaggio, però,
un altro aneddoto bellissimo
è stato in una giornata in Svezia,
quando dopo qualche decina di chilometri,
incontrai questo cartello.
Ecco.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Pronunce.
Non so quanti scandinavi
ci siano qui dentro,
però per un italiano, ovviamente,
leggere la parola "dio"
incorniciato oltretutto da questo meteo
che è impossibile da trovare
nella primavera svedese, ve lo assicuro,
poteva solamente preannunciare
una giornata idilliaca,
stupenda, fortunata,
e io avevo percepito questa cosa
e avevo aumentato l'andatura.
Ma dopo qualche decina di chilometri,
un bullone spesso come il dito di una mano
si tranciò di netto,
e la ruota proprio andò da un'altra parte
e io e il carretto da un'altra.
Rimasi lì fermo, impalato,
a bordo strada per circa 3 ore e mezza,
prima che passasse solamente
un pensionato in bicicletta,
(Risate)
che fortunatamente
si è dimostrato avere buon cuore,
perché poi è ritornato
indietro in macchina,
mi ha riportato a casa sua,
e abbiamo aggiustato
il carretto con un dado,
un bullone di una fresa agricola.
Gli ho detto: "Tu farai a meno
di tagliare l'erba per un po' di tempo,
ma almeno io arrivo a Capo Nord!"
(Risate)
Il carretto, scherzi a parte,
aveva un nome:
si chiamava "Anna Jenny 1".
È stato un nome molto pensato
e scelto da me interamente,
perché Anna è il nome della mia fidanzata,
Jenny invece è il nome
della fidanzata di Forrest Gump nel film.
(Risate)
Esatto. Chi l'ha visto...
(Applausi)
Chi ha visto il film
non può non ricordarselo.
E invece, il numero 1
stava ad indicare la mia speranza
che questa non fosse solamente
la prima avventura di tante
formanti durante la mia vita.
Ecco, questo carretto,
devo essere sincero,
è stato il mio compagno di viaggio
effettivo per 84 giorni,
abbiamo fatto di quei discorsi
filosofici assieme,
soprattutto in Lapponia,
che non sto qui a dirvi!
Però devo anche ammettere, seriamente,
che è stata la gatta più grossa
da pelare durante il mio viaggio.
Infatti in tutta la totalità
degli 84 giorni,
12 sono dovuto rimanere fermo
per aggiustare le sue tre rotture.
Cioè le mie gambe non si sono rotte,
ma si è rotto tre volte il carretto!
Ecco, ricordo ancora quando durante
la prima rottura ero incazzatissimo
e ho chiamato il mio amico in Italia
che me lo aveva saldato e gli ho detto:
"Ascolta, ma che lavoro hai fatto?"
Mi fa: "Ma perché
sei partito? Io avevo..."
Mi ha confessato che ha fatto
questo lavoro con leggerezza
perché pensava che la mia
fosse una ragazzata
e che alla fine io non fossi
nemmeno partito.
(Risate)
Quindi è stato veramente da strapparsi
i capelli con questo carretto.
Però siamo ancora amici, è tornato
a casa con me, non l'ho lasciato là!
Devo dire anche,
sempre tornando al viaggio,
che fino a metà Svezia il viaggio
è stato sì abbastanza faticoso,
ma è stato divertentissimo e, dal punto
di vista umano, è stato molto formante,
perché ho incontrato persone
che davvero mi raccoglievano dalla strada
e mi invitavano per una doccia calda,
un letto, oppure anche solamente del cibo
e mi accoglievano in casa.
Quindi è stato veramente fantastico.
Però devo ammettere che,
appunto, in un bel giorno,
più precisamente proprio il giorno
del mio compleanno, il 15 giugno,
il mio viaggio è cambiato completamente.
È cambiato completamente quando
ho incontrato questo cartello:
l'inizio della Lapponia.
Lì posso dire che veramente
era finito il mio viaggio
ed è iniziata la mia avventura.
Infatti da qui in poi,
per circa due settimane,
ho dovuto lavarmi solamente
nei fiumi e nei laghi,
perché non ho trovato
alcuna struttura per potermi ricevere,
e ho dovuto stracaricare il carretto,
fino a farlo pesare 40 chili,
con viveri, acqua e cibo, perché c'era
anche una festa nazionale di mezzo
e avevo trovato veramente
tutto chiuso per due settimane.
Voi subito direte: "Si, caspita Andrea,
questa qui allora è stata
la parte più dura,
più massacrante del tuo viaggio!"
e posso dire di sì, perché qui
ci sono arrivato abbastanza allenato:
in Lapponia riuscivo a fare anche 70
chilometri al giorno trainando 40 chili;
però devo anche dire che,
oltre alla fatica fisica,
è stato il momento
del viaggio più formante.
È dove ho maturato
i pensieri più profondi,
dove ho trovato l'essenza del vero Andrea.
Per esempio, ho capito...
la comprensione, veramente,
di potercela fare, anche se siamo da soli,
in qualsiasi situazione,
quando siamo messi alle strette.
Oppure, che una motivazione
ben radicata come la mia
possa farci superare barriere e ostacoli
che la società odierna continua
a costruirci ogni giorno attorno.
Ma soprattutto, ho imparato
a ridare, a rifare, a ricreare
una scala completa di valori,
che poi dal viaggio ho riportato
nella mia vita quotidiana.
Infatti, fidatevi che dopo aver corso
70 chilometri, magari sotto l'acqua,
io non vedevo l'ora di sentire
la voce della mia fidanzata,
non vedevo l'ora di bermi una birra
e mangiare una buona pizza,
o di dormire al caldo nella mia tenda.
Non magari come quando
ero a casa, lì tranquillo,
che non vedevo l'ora, come tutti
i ragazzi al giorno d'oggi,
di prendere in mano il telefonino,
di andare in giro a fare un po' di festa,
o di vestire degli abiti firmati.
Ecco, questa scala l'ho riportata
nella vita di tutti i giorni
e vi dico che funziona veramente,
non solo a Capo Nord,
funziona anche qui in Italia!
Però, quando sono arrivato, invece,
devo ammettere che
ho scoperto una vera verità,
ovvero che stavo commettendo un errore
davvero, davvero grosso prima di partire.
Infatti, mi sono reso conto che,
prima dell'incidente,
stavo andando a occupare una posizione,
ad incasellarmi
su una posizione, su una cella,
già predefinita da qualcun altro
e soprattutto dalla società.
Stavo seguendo questo percorso
per andare a sedermi su questa sedia,
non tracciato da me.
Invece, con l'incidente prima
e con il viaggio poi,
mi sono reso conto
di essere unico al mondo
e di avere la possibilità di tracciare
veramente il percorso della mia vita.
Quindi vi auguro davvero, innanzitutto...
Anzi, vi consiglio prima,
almeno una volta nella vita,
di fermarvi a riflettere,
perché viviamo in una società
talmente frenetica che non ce lo permette.
Ovvio che non vi auguro di stare
sdraiati in convalescenza
sei mesi in un letto come ho fatto io!
Però, invece, auguro a tutti
prima o poi di poter vivere,
almeno una volta nella vita,
il vostro sogno nel cassetto.
Io mi reputo davvero fortunatissimo,
perché ho vissuto
un sogno lungo 84 giorni.
Grazie.
(Applausi)